what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome to Halloween week on Comics
explain now for those of you guys who
are new to the Rob core Halloween week
this is the week where we cast aside our
normal schedule and we cover Halloween
stuff so I have been diligently trying
to find something that I can do on
Marvel Comics and it occurred to me the
age of Ultron versus Marvel zombie story
like this would be something really cool
to do because it's something that we've
never done and uh mostly because this
came out after Halloween last year so I
figure it would be really fun to do now
I want to provide a little bit of basis
behind this so in in Marvel Comics as we
know we saw the big secret Wars event
and the Secret Wars event was designed
to show us battle world and so on and
then lead into what we thought was a
reboot of the Marvel Universe but within
the secret Wars line of stories while a
majority of everything dealt with battle
world we also saw some Side Stories some
tie-ins that gave us these different
depictions of life within battle world
we saw stuff like a continuation of Days
of Future Past as alter reality so on
and so forth and all of this came about
because when the beyonders uh seemed to
destroy the Multiverse so when they were
laying waste to everything uh Doctor
Strange Dr Doom and the molecule man
Owen Reese defeated the beyonders and Dr
Doom used the power of the beyonders to
literally just grab all these different
universes that remain and keep what
fractions of the Multiverse he could
alive in the form of battle world and so
this segment of uh of you know the I
guess Age of Ultron versus the Marvel
Zombies this basically deals with the
bad part of battle world this deals with
the hood of battle World So within the
main territories of battle World itself
I guess around all the main territories
you have what's called The Shield or the
wall and the shield basically protects
uh everybody from a combination of the
Age of Ultron robots and the uh zombies
and the forces of annihilist now this
story initially picks up with Tigra now
Tigra is a smalltime character in the
realm of Marvel Comics she was an
Avenger for a while and I think this is
an alternate reality version of her it
doesn't really matter but she's
basically been sentenced to uh to she's
been sentenced to be sent over the wall
and that's how things work in battle
world you're not really executed
whenever you commit a crime like if you
were to cross barriers into another
realm or you were to just do something
that Dr Doom doesn't like you look at
him funny he's going to send you over
the wall and you're going to have to
survive as long as you can but most
everybody who goes over the wall is
either killed by the forces of anilus
they're killed by the Ultron robots or
they're killed by the zombies now with
Tigra trying to make her way through
here we're not really shown exactly what
it is that happens to her all we really
know is that she is sent over here and
she's being tracked by the combined
forces of the zombified uh Sabertooth
and the moleman and a host of other you
know Marvel zombies that all reside here
and of course much like the original
Marvel Zombies Story which I have you'll
find that playlist down in the
description in fact I'll throw this in
the playlist as well but in the um in
the original Marvel zombies zombies
story they basically all still have
their minds right you know they they
have their powers they have their minds
it's just they're consumed by a desire
for flesh and they all talk about this
they basically say hey look if I find
her first I'm going to eat her and and
then you guys can have whatever's left
and so it's basically every man for
himself in the realm of the Marvel
Zombies Universe now while she while
Tigra is able to hold her own against
one or two zombies the problem is that
once they all sniff her out she's
literally surrounded by all of them and
it basically seems as though she's never
going to make it out alive but the
problem with this is almost immediately
after she's cornered these zombies are
met by the arrival of the Ultron robots
who who deem them as being imperfect and
begin the process of killing them off
now this is one of the big differences
within the main battle World story
itself is part of Secret Wars you could
not cross barriers like the inhabitants
of the age of I'm sorry the inhabitants
of the Days of Future Past Universe
could not cross over into the uh Age of
Apocalypse Universe if anybody did that
they'd be sentenced over the wall and so
we don't know if this is exactly what
happened with her but within this
territory on the other side of the
shield that doesn't apply it's basically
no man's land whoever lasts longer can
and it's more or less where Doom just
turns a blind eye to everything that's
going on so for those of you guys who
watch Game of Thrones imagine this as
being on the other side side of the wall
you know on the other side of the black
wall when guys go and they serve the
black uh imagine this basically being
the territory or the domain of the
wildlings it just kind of whatever
happens happens now what we also do is
we get a little backstory here with
regards to the Age of Ultron event and
this is why James Robinson is so cool
because remember these are all alternate
realities some of which we've seen and
some of which we haven't seen but in the
reality where this Age of Ultron domain
comes from what we're told is that in
this timeline when Hank Pam created
Ultron and activated him instead of
wiping you know Hank Pimp's mind of
Ultron itself instead the Ultron robot
killed Hank Pim and because of this the
masters of evil you were were basically
successful in killing off all the
Avengers there was no one there to warn
the masters of evil of what the plan of
Ultron was that Ultron was actually a
robot that Ultron planned to dominate
the world and so the masters of evil
fought alongside Ultron they wiped out
the Avengers and then Ultron waited and
basically just built himself further
until he was at the point where we had
Ultron 8 and Ultron 99 and those forces
working together wiped out the rest of
the world superheroes I mean they killed
them all they killed the X-Men they
killed uh they killed n the Submariner
they killed storm I mean they even
killed Kitty pride and that's just
messed up cuz she was a teenager but
they kill everybody and so the result is
that this version of Ultron took over
everything now as we know when the
Multiverse collapsed this was one of the
realities that Dr Doom grabbed and
basically preserved but remember it's
only a fraction of this reality it's
only a small section so it's like a
little a little itty bitty part of you
know of what that Earth would have
looked like but the fact remains here
that we switch over to the wall itself
and the wall I guess on this wall is a
variation of Hank Pim from an alternate
reality more like a western reality or
something like that but the idea here is
that it's somewhere along the line in
his timeline he tried to create a
version of Ultron for you know his time
era a very primitive version and he had
basically crossed over barriers in order
to grab some materials that would allow
him to do this Dr Doom found out about
it and most likely at the direction of
the Thor cor which operated as the
police on Battle world this version of
Hank Pam was taken to the wall and he's
been sentenced to be thrown over this
the difference with this is that the
woman who's sentencing him or at least
who's going to be throwing him over the
wall she and Hank Pim were together for
a time and so she pulled a few strings
and I guess it's a good situation but
she pulled a few strings and he's not
going to simply just be thrown over the
wall instead he gets to decide which
part of the wall he gets to go over so
it's really tantamount to yes Hank Pim
is going to die but he gets to choose
how he's going to die uh which is really
messed up but the fact remains here that
once he makes his decisions once he's
basically told about the three
territories and that one of these
territories houses the ult robots his
Intrigue and Technology more or less
forces his hand and he decides to choose
the realm of the Ultron robots and so
once he set upon this area he begins
exploring this different territory
exploring all the different things that
are here but he eventually comes across
a couple of uh zombies that have killed
one of these Ultron robots and our
initial thought is well it's going to be
curtains for for this version of Hank
Pim right like he's going to die and
that's just the way it is like there's
there's nothing nothing to do here uh
it's the end of him but in the midst of
you know these zombies getting ready to
attack him the zombies of Rh and Owlman
I think it is which is interesting uh
they're suddenly incinerated and when
Hank Pim turns around he's met with the
arrival of this reality's versions or I
guess this Age of Ultron version of
vision and Jim Hammond the Human Torch
and Wonderman Simon Williams now from
here we switch back to the deadlands and
we pick up with Colonial Punisher and
I'm going to tell you right now Colonial
Punisher is probably the greatest thing
that I've ever seen because he's talking
trash just like the regular Punisher
does but he's using like Colonial
phrases you know so he's like he's like
come carry on come rank in base company
and come one come all Let's Dance a Mary
jig that's amazing and and I really wish
the Punisher talked like this more often
but again this just basically shows us
that almost anybody who's thrown over
the wall is going to be completely
incinerated but the difference is that
again much like Tigra where Colonial
Punisher I really want to see him in all
new all different Marvel I just want to
say that I really want to see more
Colonial Punisher but while a colonial
Punisher is trying to get away from the
the from the zombies uh these various
zombies or I guess he is suddenly
incinerated by the Ultron robots and one
of the Ultron robots version 432
basically says that uh these all these
different you know zombies are
considered to be imperfect and because
the mission of the Ultron robots is to
purify everything that is imperfect
they're going to wipe out these zombies
so again this is really just James
Robinson setting the stage for uh you
know for for what's going on with this
reality to basically show us how bad
things are going to be now jumping back
to the shield what we learn is that this
woman that had sentenced Hank Pam or I
guess had given Hank Pam the opportunity
to decide where he was going to go this
is actually the Western version of Janet
vany from the Western Marvel Universe
line of stories which by the way are
absolutely amazing but it seems as
though she's effectively a band in her
shift and it seems as though she's going
into the realm of these Ultron robots
for the purpose of grabbing Hank Pim and
bringing him back now jumping back to
Hank Pim alongside uh vision and Jim
Hammond and and Simon Williams we
learned that they've actually built this
giant Refuge within the realm of this
Age of Ultron territory not only that it
doesn't house just them it also houses a
multitude of other superheroes as well
basically people who were able to
survive the Age of Ultron timeline and
had uh hidden out within this realm that
has a force field that either Ultron
doesn't know about or Ultron is unable
to get past but what what we're told or
at least what what I suspected anyway
was that when this initial timeline was
created that Jim Hammond and you know
that Simon Williams and vision were able
to survive simply because of the fact
that they're Androids or at least uh two
of them are Androids and that's exactly
what we're told what we're informed is
that because Jim Hammond was an Android
he was created as the original Human
Torch by uh by whatever his doctor's
name was I can't remember um that he
basically is considered to be perfect in
the eyes of Ultron because Ultron
doesn't view him as a normal human being
not only that the vision was created by
Ultron so the vision I guess Ultron
views the vision as his son so to speak
now Simon Williams is a whole different
Beast here and the reason why I say that
is yes the vision was created using the
brain patterns of Simon Williams the
difference is that once Simon Williams
was you know considered to have been
dead he was reconstituted using ionic
energy and so he's basically energy in
human form and so we can't technically
be killed by Ultron and so as a result
he just kind of exists off on his own
now when Ultron began the process of
taking over the world you know vision
and Jim Hammond and Simon Williams
didn't really like what it was that
Ultron was doing and so the result was
that they began to you know collude
against Ultron and they began to kill
off ultron's robots effectively rebelled
against him and in response they began
to create a Salvation of sorts for
themselves and built this Refuge to not
only house them but to also grab
whatever survivors were out there and
bring them to this location in order to
ensure that they didn't have to deal
with the uh being eradicated by Ultron
and so what this does is this
effectively creates a situation whereby
we now have Hank Pam from this Western
Universe with the base of operations but
he also has you know a desire and a
knowledge for technology but he's also
wildly smart even for his own generation
and so the idea here is that they bring
him to this location for the purpose of
more or less figuring out a way to
defeat Ultron itself and so from here we
transition to the main Citadel of Ultron
and what we learn is that instead of
Ultron and these zombies at least
seeming to fight each other right off
the bat instead a kind of Packa has been
struck and the Ultron robots are working
alongside Magneto who seems to be the
leader of these uh of these zombies and
the idea is that they're going to join
forces and they're effectively going to
go into battle World itself they're
going to cast off Dr Doom and they're
going to take everything over now they
both have different motives here because
the zombies just want to consume people
the zombies would really work as a
purifier of sorts for the Ultron robots
and the sense of the zombies would go in
and they would wipe out all the
different humans and they would probably
just consume them in their entirety and
not really give them the opportunity to
become uh to become zombies and this
would basically set the stage for the
Ultron robots to go in and to simply
just take over to basically just
establish base of operations and so on
and so forth what we're going to learn
is that the most predictable scenario
unfold holds as a result of this now
transitioning back to the sanctuary with
Hank Pim and vision and Jim Hammond and
Simon Williams where this story
initially seemed uh interesting in terms
of how it was unfolding at this point it
just goes completely off the rails so
what we learn is that yes Jim Hammond is
a synthetic man uh except for a
particular area of himself and the
reason why we know that this area is not
synthetic is because he got a chick
pregnant now how it is that a synthetic
man impregnates a woman is a question I
do not have the answer to uh and I'm
sure nobody else does either but this
was apparently something that was
entirely possible in the realm of Marvel
Comics but having said that we also
learned that each of these individuals
has someone that they've lashed on to
they have basically a person in their
life that is their significant other
sometimes these people are are half
hybrid you know human and machine
sometimes they're completely human but
whatever the case may be it's really
just you know James Robinson giving us a
view of the fact that each of these
individuals has created a life for
themselves especially when when it comes
to the case of vision we know Vision as
a person being in a relationship with
the Scarlet Witch Wanda Maxim off but it
seems as though when the Age of Ultron
event initially occurred in this reality
and Hank Pim was killed and the rest of
the superheroes were destroyed that
Agatha harness who's a legitimate witch
was one of the survivors and it seemed
as though she had basically developed a
relationship with vision which is kind
of weird because she's really old but
the fact remains here that again you
know with with Janet van we we also get
a little bit of backstory between her
and Hank Pim from this Western reality
and we learn that Janet vany was
basically working in a burlesque house
and that Hank Pam himself had been
working on again this this mechanical
man but because of the fact that he had
reached out to locations that were
outside of the realm he had drawn the
attention of the Thor core and the
result of this was that the Thor core
had taken him prisoner and basically you
know sentenced him to being thrown over
the wall now transitioning back to
Ultron and the zombies my initial
thought was that the you know Ultron and
the zombies were going to turn on one
another what we learned is that Ultron
had actually found a way to merge uh his
ulton technology along with the zombies
into a single entity and the reason why
he does this is he says that
individually there's no way they can
penetrate the forces of the sanctuary
kill everybody inside and then expand
their reach into a battle World itself
he says that in order for them to be
successful they have to basically meld
the zombies and the Ultron robots into
singular beings which will enhance their
power in a multitude of different ways
now when this happens and they
immediately launch an attack against the
uh against the sanctuary and the forces
of of Hank pan and uh vision and and
Wonderman Simon Williams and so on the
initial question is what do they do next
you know what do they do now and what
happens is Hank Pam comes to the
realization that by studying the Ultron
technology by studying you know how the
Ultron robots work that they all
basically have a hive mind and when
Ultron had begun the process of
experimenting and merging the Ultron
robots into zombies God this story is
ridiculous by merging the Ultron zombies
into uh into I guess merging the Ultron
robots into the the zombie bodies that
he had used the energy of Simon Williams
to do it now Simon Williams wasn't
lending his energy in this situation
Ultron had basically just learned how to
duplicate the ion energy and as a result
these zombies SL Ultron robots basically
all share a hive mind meaning if they
can disrupt the signal they can shut
down all of these zombiie SL Ultron
robots and uh and be free of their in
you know their Insanity the problem with
this is that it would basically combine
the life Essence so to speak of Jim
Hammond and the vision in Simon Williams
to pull it off and so what each of these
guys do is they begin the process of
saying their goodbyes now for Jim
Hammond this is a huge deal because
again somehow he got a woman pregnant
but he's basically walking away from the
prospect of being a father for vision
he's walking away from his significant
other and the same thing with um with
Simon Williams and so again you know
this is really just James Robinson kind
of giving us a a scenario sort of an
ironic situation that the creator of
Ultron or or someone who was capable of
creating Ultron would in turn create a
way to defeat Ultron so it's just sort
of the situation that everything goes in
Full Circle but it's also highlighting
the idea that this version of Hank Pim
is not nearly as smart as the version of
Hank Pim that originally created Ultron
just because he doesn't have the same
access to the same kind of Technologies
but it also shows us that with enough
time he can learn what he needs in order
to pull this off and so with the Ultron
SL zombies breaking into the sanctuary
getting past the force field and uh you
know basically killing off all these
different survivors uh when the
situation seems at its worst and it
seems as though the you know Dr Octopus
version or it looks like a Dr Octopus
version of uh the of the zombies was
going to attack um you know Hank Pim
ultimately Janet vany makes her arrival
and she's able to uh to save his life
and so from here we basically have him
activating the machine this this sort of
pulse and uh Simon Williams vision and
Jim Hammond getting inside and allowing
their allowing to merge with the signal
in order to send out an energy uh pulse
to all the Ultron robots that ultimately
reboots them more or less it allows Hank
Pim to control all of them individually
as part of a colle itive whole and
basically turn them into a police force
that essentially just guards the
entirety of uh of this sanctuary and
that's where the story ends um this is
probably one of the worst stories I've
ever read but at the very least it was
interesting um it fits into the
Halloween theme I guess you know with
regards to zombies and stuff but it's no
wonder why this story got uh rough
reviews it's
uh Ultron robots merging with Marvel
Zombies is a stretch in and of itself
what we saw here I don't even know how
to begin to describe uh it went totally
off the rails it's the best best way I
know how to describe this anyway uh if
you agree that this comic was rough
around the edges uh make sure you guys
hit the sub button become part of the
robore and um yeah make sure you guys
drop a like and leave a comment let me
know what you all think cuz I'm kind of
curious and I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace